well the best the best advice for fellow
actors is this know what your job is
about 18 years ago I had this cognition
that I realized I was going into
auditions trying to get a job
and that simply wasn't what I was doing
I wasn't what I said what I'm supposed
to be doing an actor is supposed to
create a compelling interesting
character that serves the text we
presented in
where your audition
and then you walk away and that's it
everything else is out of your control
so don't even think of it don't focus on
it you're not going there to get a job
they're going to present what you do you
act and there it is and walk away when
there's power in them there's confidence
in them and it's also saying I can only
do so much and then the decision of who
might get a job is so out of your
control that it really when you analyze
it it makes no sense to hold on to that
that to me was a breakthrough and once I
adapted that philosophy I never looked
back and I've never been busier in my
life then once I grabbed onto
that's it